Dear me, first and foremost,
please get some sleep.
You are the only one
responsible
for your own happiness.
Stop trying so hard
to please your parents.
Stop trying so hard to be
someone you're not.
Just be yourself
and love yourself.
And stop trying to get people
to like you.
Don't try to fit in.
You were born to stick out.
Don't cut your hair just
because you have lice.
It's okay to experiment,
but be mindful.
Be confident, because that's
really one of the only things
that people actually notice.
Ignore them.
Those are #DearMe videos,
where grownups give advice
to their teenage selves,
because they don't understand
how the space-time continuum
works.
What is this, The Lake House?
Check the mailbox;
see if there's any letters
from the future.
They asked me to participate,
and since kids love stupid
inspirational crap, I agreed.
But, apparently,
they edited me out.
[laughs]
Lucky for you,
I went back in time
and got my hands
on an earlier version.
Dear me, look how awesome
your life turns out.
Screw saving money.
Just keep doing you, buddy.
Junior high, it can be
a rough place.
Don't get too attached
to Devin.
He will die in a gruesome
car accident real soon.
A lot of the friends you thought
were your friends, they're not.
Do not sweat
any pregnancy scares.
I don't know how you do it,
but you dodge bullets, baby.
When you recover
from anorex--
When you're in Dallas,
stay away from a dessert
called the Pizookie,
unless you feel
like telling a story
about [bleep] your pants
in a hotel lobby
for the rest of your life.
Having your period
is the worst thing in--
Basically,
from the age of 18 on,
I need you to keep toilet paper,
wet naps,
a full change of clothes,
and shoes in the car.
You do survive--
Find a kid named Mark Zuckerberg
and murder him.
You will be doing the world
a huge favor.
And also tell your family
about any pain--
All right, one day, the Dolphins
are gonna have to decide
between Drew Brees
and Daunte Culpepper.
I'm gonna need you
to convince them
his shoulder will be fine
and they should go with
Drew Brees.
God, you had
such a big crush on--
If a certain ballerina
catches your eye
during a performance of
Swan Lake, trust me.
Do not go backstage to meet her.
That's a life sentence
you will quietly regret
until death do you part.
So save yourself the drama
and a lot of time
and just go to the--
Snowpiercer.
I cannot stress this enough.
Do not watch that movie.
It is horrible.
If you're 13 right now,
you're going to have
a pretty difficult--
You're gonna be in New York
in 2001
just killing it on Letterman.
Congrats.
I need you to stick around
an extra week
and see if you can stop
a little something called 9/11.
Good luck.
You push the people that--
Just focus on the clitty.
I remember
not feeling black--
Y2K is real.
You will need months
of clean water, all right?
A secure bunker,
heavy artillery.
Trust no one.
The first kill is gonna be
difficult,
but just keep shooting.
If that helps one dirtbag
teenager in Titusville, Florida,
then it was worth it.